every 39 seconds there is a Cyber attack
and 4 million files are stolen every day
that's 44 every single second sounds
scary right well it's true as well the
world is brimming with possibilities
with remote work cloud storage social
media digital avatars and what node but
so is the possibility of being tricked
scammed and exploited by those cyber
criminals lurking in the dark corners of
the internet waiting for you to make one
wrong move cyber security and
information security are some of the
biggest challenges that modern
civilization faces with that being said
hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learn YouTube channel today we will be
discussing cyber security and what
skills you must learn to become a
successful cyber security expert it is
evident that such huge risk in the world
of Internet Security is of utmost
importance and organizations are betting
heavily or professionals who have the
right skill for a cyber security role
You Must Be Wondering though where must
I start do not worry in this video we'll
specifically deal with understanding how
you can start learning cyber security
and what top skills can you land a job
in the field of cyber security so
without further Ado let's jump to the
topic of the video but before that make
sure to subscribe to our Channel and hit
the like button and the bell icon to
never miss any further updates and
before we begin if you are someone who
is interested in building a career in
cyber security by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
then try doing a show to Simply lens
postgraduate program in cyber security
that is with modules from MIT schwarzman
College of Engineering and the link to
this course is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete order of the program being
offered so now we'll start with the
topic that is cyber security skills and
we'll start with the introduction and
the demand for cyber Security
Professionals is increasing each year
due to the growing skills Gap and the
escalating threat of cyber crime so to
secure the best job opportunity it is
cyber Security Experts need to acquire
Advanced skills and knowledge and now
let's explore the top sort after cyber
security skills for 2023 and cyber
security is a complex field that
involves protecting networks systems and
applications as well as recovering data
after cyber attacks so by acquiring the
following highly desired cyber security
skills that will be covering and that
are the 10 skills we will be covering so
motivated individuals can pursue a
rewarding career in this field so
starting with the first skill that is
Proficiency in network and system
administration a strong grasp of
networking exclusion including knowledge
of data transmission protocols and
services that Safeguard and
organizations data familiarity with
network protocols like TCP UCP HTTP icmp
DNS and SMTP as well as network security
devices such as firewalls and load
balancers is essential additionally
understanding Technologies like ndr EDM
here xdr NAC and sasc is valuable
familiarize yourself with network and
point extended detection and response
systems that is ndl EDR XTR network
access control NAC and secure access
Services
Technologies and practical experience
through labs and certifications can help
reinforce your understanding and the
next skills you should have expertise in
Cloud security so building secure
architectures that facilitate
interactions between applications and
the cloud is in high demand companies
seek professionals skilled in securing
public and hybrid Cloud platforms like
Azure AWS and gcp to master Cloud
security start by gaining expertise in
popular Cloud platforms like Azure AWS
and gcp understand their security
features including identity and access
management data protection and
encryption knowledge of containerization
Technologies like kubernetes is also
desirable Proficiency in web application
firewall Waf and identity and access
management IEM is crucial for protecting
Cloud infrastructure hands-on experience
with Cloud platforms practical projects
and relevance certifications will
enhance your skills and now we'll see
another skill that is the third skill
application security skills so with the
increasing number of applications
targeted by hackers organizations need
professionals who can design Implement
and maintain secure applications
knowledge of software and application
development processes as well as the
ability to identify and mitigate common
security threads is vital learn about
secure coding practices vulnerability
assessment and threat modeling
understand common security threats to
web and software applications such as
injection attacks and cross-site
scripting explore tools and Frameworks
like owasb top 10 and learn how to
mitigate these vulnerabilities
practicing secure coding techniques and
contributing to open source projects can
help Define your skills and now we'll
see the fourth skill that is a
penetration testing alongside Network
operating system and application
security expertise familiarity with
standard hacking tools and techniques is
important understand how hackers think
and work and develop knowledge of common
vulnerabilities penetration testers
stimulate real world attacks to identify
vulnerabilities and develop strategies
for mitigation Proficiency in
penetration testing tools like nessus
Metasploit SQL map and Joe Fish is
valuable engage in Hands-On Labs Capture
the Flag challenges and Bug Bounty
programs to gain practical experience
and sharpen your skills now we'll talk
about the another skill that is risk
assessment and management so the ability
to assess and mitigate risk is an
integral part of a cyber security skill
set understanding security incident and
event monitoring Siem Technologies can
actively facilitating risk assessments
and security operations are significant
skills in this domain learn how to
proactively identify and access security
risk acquire knowledge of risk
mitigation strategies and incident
response processes practical experience
through simulated scenarios case studies
and Industry standard Frameworks like
nist can enhance your risk assessment
skills now we'll talk about another
skill that is digital forensic and
incident response so skilled
professionals who can investigate cyber
attacks recover and lost data identify
the origins of attacks and strengthen
cyber security defenses are sought after
learn forensic investigation techniques
manual analysis and incident response
procedures Proficiency in networking
programming critical thinking and
forensic software tools such as encase
Helix xry nftx is necessary hands-on
experience with simulated incident
response exercises and participating in
cyber security competitions can
strengthen your dfir skills and now
we'll see another skill that is
programming and database language so
programming skills are essential in
cyber security Proficiency in languages
like C C plus plus PHP python go Ruby
HTML MySQL JavaScript Hadoop and dotnet
helps understand attackers strategies
and enable secure interactions between
applications and the cloud so understand
database languages like SQL for managing
and securing data engage in coding
projects contribute to open source
projects and solve programming
challenges to improve your programming
skills now we'll see another skill that
is Linux proficiency so Linux skills are
highly valued in the cyber security
field due to its open source nation and
flexibility for Network scanning and
system service usage familiarity with
Linux distributions like Kali Linux
specially designed for penetration
testing and digital forensics is
beneficial and the next skill is data
security skills so data security
governance program oversight and
continuous development are
responsibilities of cyber Security
Professionals compliance with data
security regulations such as gdpr PCI
HIPAA nist crpa ceramin Oxley and fips
is crucial additionally expertise in
configuring running and maintaining
databases is essential for safeguarding
data against threats like DDOS attacks
phishing and ransomware and now we'll
see another skill that is business
leadership skill the Cyber Security
Professionals must raise awareness among
employees and train them in recognizing
suspicious behaviors and protecting
against cyber attacks effective
communication influence emotional
intelligence and problem solving
abilities are essential for
collaboration within teams to identify
system weaknesses and develop Ropers
defense lines and now these are the
skills that you should be proficient for
a cyber security professional and
despite reports of layoffs in the tech
industry the demand for cyber Security
Professionals is expected to grow
significantly skilled individuals in
this field continue to receive
competitive compensation packages even
in Industries cutting back on spending
experience and training in these
critical areas differentiate cyber
security candidates and place their
resumes at the top of the list remember
mastering these skills requires a
combination of theoretical knowledge and
practical experience pursuing relevant
certifications engaging in Hands-On
projects participating in cyber security
communities and staying updated with
industry Trends and best practices will
help you excel in each of these areas
and this was all for this cyber security
skills you needed in 2023 and I hope you
guys found it informative and helpful
now let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers by opting to
simply land courses hi I'm Philip I'm 61
years old and last year I upskilled with
simply learned postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the I.T sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with Infosys
as a cyber security consultant
happened on the first and if you like
this session then like share and
subscribe if you have any questions then
you can drop them in the comment section
below thanks for watching stay tuned for
more from Simply love staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign